I'm advocating for the components of
video games especially the engaging ones
to be ported into classroom instruction
because the audience the students
clearly understand the media video games
contain the blueprint for engaging
education because of the way that they
cater to human learning a complex story
interwoven with learning content and a
bit of artificial intelligence for
difficulty and balance online
instruction can be enhanced if schools
turn to top streaming platforms and
streamers to learn how to effectively
engage students online and the
objectives for Education overall need to
be as specific as a video game so that
those who are enrolled have a clear line
of sight to where they're headed if we
can start showing students how their
passion for playing connects to their
Futures we will have done our jobs